[Music]
welcome to film independent presents i
am drea clark i'm producer-in-residence
at film independent and i co-host a film
podcast called maximum film on the
maximum fun network before we get
started with tonight's conversation i
want to give some praise to our loyal
supporters so thank you to our lead
sponsor the hollywood foreign press
association and neon for making the
special night happen
all right nicholas cage
i'm so excited you're here and you have
a tinsel tree behind you it's a
christmas miracle
thank you well i'm happy to be invited
to this i'm excited about our
conversation
and getting some interesting questions
to answer excellent well i can get right
into that obviously you are someone who
needs no introduction especially since
the film independent audience is largely
comprised of definite film lovers and a
lot of them are filmmakers themselves
so they are well aware of you if anyone
has seen less than 10 of his films
however please drop me a line i'm happy
to send an enthusiastic viewing list of
many more nicholas cage films you can
check out so
um jumping right in i would love to talk
first about
elements of your career as a whole and
sort of approach to acting in general
and then we'll dig into pig at the end
um and then open it up to a couple of
questions from the audience but starting
off with that overview
you have created so many memorable
characters i'm sure many people have
like thrown lines back to you in the
form of those characters over the years
ronnie and moonstruck castor troy and
faceoff mcdonald bad lieutenant port of
new call new orleans
but what stands out to me is that
regardless of how wild or different the
characters are
they're unified by a sense of sincerity
so even a movie like mom and dad which
could have easily been played with a
wink
is fully committed and so i'd love to
start off by asking you is avoiding
irony something you have in mind when
you're considering roles
or is sincerity something that you just
naturally bring to performances
outstanding question it really is and
i'm glad you asked and thank you for
what you noticed
um a couple things that come to mind one
is that i in my quest to figure out a
way to break form with that which is
naturalism and become more operatic or
more uh
kabuki if you will
what some folks call over the top
i
i wanted
to find mechanisms
within the character
whether it be
mental illness or alcoholism or drug
addiction or
uh
you know
massive tragedy or whatever it is that
would allow me to organically
inform with genuine emotion
the bizarre behavior the opera the what
i'm trying to graph or design as a
kabuki presentation
uh so that it never felt even as big or
crazy or wild as people said that is
what you hooked into was exactly what i
wanted which is that there was truth
behind it there was sincerity behind it
there was that which was emotionally
informed so it wasn't just
wild for wildness sake it had to have
genuine
um it had to have a genuine sense of
emotion that got this character whomever
it may be to that level
but having said that
there and i have avoided irony i've
actually gone i've actually gone because
i i was born with a pretty silver tongue
i could i could you know go against
anyone in terms of
being sarcastic or sardonic or whatever
it was and i i wanted to actively avoid
that i wanted to actively
get away from sarcasm and and irony and
get more into emotional nakedness and
you know to the point of where it might
even seem embarrassing but
that being said there is value
on in some style
like oscar wilde or or uh
you know charles grodin or david
letterman where they they have a wit and
a form and a comedic approach that is
not without its values so i i also can
play or dance around that but that's not
my fundamental interest my fundamental
interest is to
is to inform
large design it's all graphed out it's
all choreographed
with actual emotion they have to go
together they can't just be oh let's
freak out and there's no there's no
point behind it even in vampires kiss
where i'm doing the alphabet you know a
b c d funny and crazy as it is this guy
is having a nervous breakdown and so
there has to be truth
oh yeah well no peter like that's a
great example peter in vampire's kiss is
someone who
has a full fundamental belief in what
he's going through that's what's driving
the narrative that is the drama and i've
always found like that's a i have a soft
spot for that film and i think that
to me those kinds of performances
make a lot of sense because that
character is feeling that way so if
that's your intent you're nailing it
well thank you because what's
interesting about that
is
i wanted to find a way to go back to the
german expressionistic style
like nosferatu or cabinet of dr caligari
and do it in a modern movie at that time
modern it was in the 80s and
i thought well how can i do this
and still like have all those gestures
like the the the eyes and all that which
later became a meme and i also put in
face off but i discovered on vampire's
kiss i was like how can i do this german
expressionistic style
but still have it be rooted in something
organic there's truth that well that is
because peter is losing his mind i mean
he's losing his mind so he can think
he's nosferatu and i can therefore
behave or or stylize design a german
expression approach to modern film
performance
well that leads to
i think that everything i've read of
yours and even that answer speaks to
you having this deep pool of
artistic references or performance
references that you're using as
inspiration for particular characters
and roles and i i feel like your
method for for however it may change is
that idea of maybe for a lot of these
having a specific reference if it's
nosferatu or if it's um you've mentioned
talismans that you've had or art pieces
that have inspired certain things and
i'd love to know like how that approach
has evolved over the years
and what were memorable inspirations
that you drew from for certain
characters well i can think of uh
well let me begin with my concept which
was that what you could do
in one art form
you could probably do in another and if
you consider film performance and art
form then this concept of art
synchronicity does apply
and the examples that come to mind are
you know for example when i did wild at
heart
um
people think that was me imitating elvis
but the reality is it was more my andy
warhol approach to that character
because what warhol would do is he would
take these
incredible icons and he would make these
wonderful collages out of them now
stanislavski would say
the worst thing an actor can do is to
copy you know and stanislavski you know
i read his book and i i followed his his
program but
i also being a bit of a rebel wanted to
see if that if we could break form with
that because you have to sometimes break
rules in an effort to find new things
and so
when i when i went to david lynch and
said you know i had this idea
um and i had found this snakeskin jacket
in a second-hand store
and i said i'd like to to you know try
to bring
an elvis presley affectation to sailor
ripley sailor being this sort of outlaw
kind of uh
50s style guy
would probably
look up to elvis or
channel elvis in some way as an idol to
help him get through whatever he's
contending with the love of his life
and then i thought
i would like to
wear this snakeskin jacket and david
wrote that beautiful line this jacket is
a symbol of my belief in personal
freedom and
individuality and and
i thought i'd like this to be
sailor ripley is
cage as
um
elvis as marlon brando and the fugitive
kind in the snakeskin jacket that was
all because of this idea of warhol and
how could i bring that
that his presentation to film
performance then if we look at
ghostwriter the transformation scene
like that
i i was an enormous admirer of monks the
shout so i was trying to figure out how
to bring that into film performance and
i used it for
um for the transformation scene so those
are little examples of what i was
thinking in terms of the idea of aren't
synchronicity
i like that i think there's something
too and it definitely ties into the
warhol concept of gertrude stein's look
at repetition as
repeating something as a way to
recontextualize it and find new meaning
like a rose as a rose as a rose so the
idea that sailor ripley was
a version of elvis but through this lens
is that idea that repetition is
garnering new meaning in a way that's
great
yeah i don't know on my mind in those
terms but that does i see value in that
that works yeah it's an intuitive
process too um well so kind of along
those lines in a specific film of yours
that i love adaptation
where you famously played twins charlie
and donald kaufman um there's this scene
that's become very special to me where
um donald goes on about we are what we
love not what loves us
and it's something that i've had very
earnest
discussions with and it's really the
earnest open-hearted delivery of donald
saying those lines that stuck with me
and i've carried that into my own work
in my own life
and
adaptation also mentions auras boros so
there's this really fascinating circle
to be drawn between what you're taking
in as an appreciator and outputting as
an artist and now what others are taking
in and outputting from your work so i'm
wondering how do you feel about people
or artists or actors who've been finding
the same inspirations in your
performances as you've found in others
work i think that is
what
we're all
hoping for that that is communication
and all
all artists all actors
are my brothers and sisters um and if we
can borrow or
get inspired by one another then then
the communication is
is alive and i would also offer that
i've been blessed
to work with
some of the best creative forces in the
industry and charlie kaufman
who wrote adaptation i mean that was all
from him that was his
mind his imagination and
and i was so
i revered him so much that i didn't
improvise one line everything was
to the letter and
he was very thankful about that because
i couldn't have done that without him
that was
and i'm glad you mentioned that scene
because that
i got a lot out of that scene that scene
helps me in my own life or it did help
me i mean
you know
now i'm i'm happily married but it there
were times when i needed to know like it
doesn't matter
if she doesn't love me back that's my
love i love her you know and so
um
if it's on the page
you know if it's really well written an
actor can take this and and and find it
and doesn't have to really force
anything it's already there it's always
beautifully written you know so i have
to thank charlie for that
that's great
and that one of course is like just to
me such an acting achievement of i don't
think people understand our this
audience might because like i said a lot
of them are filmmakers but playing two
roles
against each other is one thing but
the
what what i took away from charlie and
donald was that you were able to take
two men who came from the same
background literally were inhabiting the
same vehicle of your body
and
i would know which one they were with a
breath like they were so different
and shaping them that differently was
just such an achievement well i have to
say i mean i don't
ever like to really
complain about
the degree of difficulty with film
performance because
i wanted to always seem like it was easy
but i i do
have to point out that i don't think i
could do that one again i i i'm glad i
was the age i was when i did it because
that was some of the most acrobatic
mind-altering
crafting i i've ever had to do
to go from one character to the other
and switch back and take places
throughout the day and
it
it got to the point where i i literally
had to go into work every morning and
say to spike the director
you know uh you'd be like what what do
you want to start with today i was like
well if i got out of the
that side of the bed and i was a little
a little cranky i think we better go
with charlie or if i got on the other
side of the bed i was
upbeat and feeling pretty good i said
let's go with donald but then you'd have
to go back to charlie and
so you have to switch from once
mindset to another set three or four
times a day and then on top of which
you had to like
look at a
tennis ball on a mic stand and imagine
that's your twin brother
and then
have an earwig in your
ear playing back what you recorded
either was donald or charlie back and
talk or act with that
pre-recording and that means you have to
get the line in the subsequent or the uh
responding line in
in that amount of time so that the
scenes could still work and i just think
it's um
it's not something that that was easily
done i i did it
because i was a huge admirer of what
jeremy irons got up to with david in in
uh
dead ringers yeah that was really
something i thought i i guess one of the
great challenges for me would be to play
twins and then again later in life like
most recently this movie unbearable
weight of massive talent i did it again
and i was like
i i'm
that's um
i now i know why it was so
so so draining on on adaptation because
you know i'm playing one version of
me and then i'm playing a different
version of me and we're trying to act
off of each other and it was just like a
kind of a i had a little bit of ptsd on
that one but it's it's uh it is a
challenge and i do
i do recommend it for
any thespians out there tonight you know
if you have an opportunity to to do it
you know just just so here we go let's
you know bring it on and
you know think of it as
like a like a piano concerto or
something and just say you're going to
learn it and learn it and learn we're
going to get it and there's going to be
surprises but
be prepared for that
great well it definitely you're right it
looked much easier i wasn't even ever
thinking about like the technical
elements i was just so impressed how
different the guys were
um i didn't mean to cut you off so
following up like in terms of working
with spike jones obviously
is now like a very highly esteemed but
you've also worked with a lot of
emerging directors including michael
sarnoski and we can discuss him later
but i feel
in looking again at your performances
which are so immersive and fully
committed it seems like even more of a
leap of faith than maybe every actor
takes when
aligning with the director like you're
handing a performance to someone
hopefully collaborating with them but
you're putting so much trust in their
hands of how they're going to utilize it
and the world they're building
around that performance you're giving
them so i'd love to hear from you of how
do directors earn your trust like do you
have any great examples of
you know people who knew to what space
to work in or how to collaborate with
you best to like
use the nicholas cage energy
well i think
it's always
important to
have communication
and to sort of understand one another's
uh process
that is
the director and the and the actor
together uh
and it changes you know sometimes you
you get a feel for a director and what
their approach might be and and you
understand that it's very important to
the
i got to the point where my job as an
actor is to facilitate the director's
vision
and part of that means what is the tone
what is what is the tone of this movie
because i want to fit within this frame
that you're creating
and i think they need to know
that they can trust that
from me that i'm trying to
help them achieve their vision
and they know you know by now at least
they know when they cast me that there's
a different collection of possibilities
that they can choose from i think uh
joel cohn
i'm back way back on raising arizona
said working with nick is like uh
dining at a smorgasbord you have all
these different things you can choose
from and you can put it together a
smorgasbord okay well i'll i like that i
want to
present different ideas i think the
the directors for me and it's become
more and more
apparent to me the best directors
are the ones that don't fix what isn't
broken the ones that trust
their actors the ones that
collaborate with their actors and trust
and
allow them you know to to find something
come in maybe do one or two takes and
and then come in and sculpt but
keep the
the creative spirit alive don't don't
impinge on it don't try to cave it in
but
encourage it and inspire it let the
actor feel um
uh that he's loved or she's loved and
like when i did matchstick man with
ridley scott which is one of my favorite
movies i've ever made um
you know i came in and ridley and i were
talking and we were getting to know each
other and i said you know really i read
the script and yes he has ocd but
i think
knowing a little bit about that
condition and
knowing
what it can lead to i think there might
be a tourette's element to this
character
and i'd like to try something because
well you know nick you find it
and then bring it to me so that was
trust and he let me go and find it and i
i added a lot to that that was not in
the script but that the fact that he
had that level of trust i felt liberated
and that i could bring something so it's
it's always um
it's always changing you know sometimes
a director is just this is what we're
doing like paul schrader you know it
won't be big and i go well
paul it doesn't have to be big that's
not all i can do i can do whatever you
know
so i just came in and i made it as
contained as i could for him different
directors have different requirements
and i've been lucky that i've worked
with some of the best and they've
allowed me to
to collaborate with them if they wanted
me to bring a certain something i would
uh or if they wanted me to just stay in
a certain place i also would
that's why i feel like you're such a for
a leading man
star you have a very journey man actor
um mentality to me like oh the
opportunity to it
i'm a student i'm a student i see myself
as a student i'm always looking to learn
something that's my attitude that is my
mindset and that's why i love working
with young people i love working with
young actors because i get so much
inspiration from them and i can ask them
like well what if what do you think if i
do this and they'll give me their honest
opinion and i listen you know
it's great i mean it's it is any craft
any work that can be considered a craft
although truthfully any work you can
always be getting better at um but not
everyone has that mentality and i do
think it comes across
with the range like you know you have
sort of tool box of emotions available
to you and you seem like happy to play
with all of those tools
given you know whatever you're building
at the time
i agree with that
all right toolbox analogy successful
um
so you know we
many actors producer types that we talk
to don't mention films like the cabinet
of dr caligari so you're someone clearly
with like a deep knowledge and respect
for old hollywood classic cinema um do
you watch new films with the same kind
of fervor and interest oh yeah
absolutely um
i'm very excited by jim cummings i i
just
you know we've become friendly and
i i just had to reach out after i saw
thunder road and i just said jim
you just blew my mind go man go you know
and i saw his beta test and i just you
know for me he's what i had aspired to
be you know i i but i never quite got
there in terms of what jerry lewis would
call the total filmmaker jerry was also
my friend before he passed on and i read
his book the total filmmaker and it was
all about if you really want to be
a filmmaker you got to do it all
baby or however he was it come on you
got to do it on the back you got to you
got to write it you gotta produce it you
gotta compose it you gotta you know
and you gotta direct it and and and
jim is that you know he's doing it all
he's doing it all outside the system
he's building it he don't need he don't
need anybody he can just do it him he
just makes it out of the you know from
scratch and that i i enjoy but i also
never forget
my roots my ancestors i i just went on
an edward g robinson kick and i was just
like my god he was good wasn't he great
look at him with james cagney and smart
money look at those two what is this
about actors revolution and ooda hogg
and i mean
james cagney and public enemy is as
natural and as real as anything that's
happening post brando i mean it's
it was all there from the get-go and i
happen to know from very high up that
marlon brano's influence was uh
um
um wow cute i lost my trans thoughts
uh paul muni paul muni
looking up to paul muni so i mean and
that's way back too so i mean yeah i
never forget to to look in the present
and look forward to the future and look
at my roots um
edward g robinson uh
you know uh anton wallbrook and in the
red shoes uh
you know
conrad veat and cabinet of dr calgary
max shrek and nosferatu
betty davis
wow i saw her just the other day i was i
had to watch all about eve again
and you could hear the whiskey and the
cigarettes in her voice but she didn't
miss a note it was like
a bach piano concerto i was like how is
she doing that and i was just like i
don't think they
i don't think they make them like that
anymore this is this is uh this is a
this is like
uh
leonard bernstein level of film
performance and
and i thought well who could who could
match that who today is really i said
maybe yeah kate blenchat she's he's that
that's who came to mind for me as well
all about eve is also incredible because
she has like perfect dialogue and then
she's giving you exquisite delivery with
it
yeah and her moves i mean she just you
can't take your eyes off of her
she's another great i mean to make a
weird comparison with her and donald
kaufman but that idea of perspective and
carriage and how that's everything
of how people read you of the you know
the sort of power you command all of
that like it's all in the
instrument as it were yeah
at the end and that is probably
for me the best example of that betty
davis
that's fantastic i love knowing that um
okay well it is time
to move to our beautiful beast of the
hour we can dig into pig a phrase that i
promised i was not going to say but i
did it nonetheless
i'm very excited right now because i'm
not critic so i don't need to be
impartial because i have such genuine
love for this film
i saw it months ago and then re-watched
it last night where it was appropriately
cold i was cold the whole time
which seemed fitting strangely so i'm
happy to be effusive i'm confident that
this film is going to
move so many people and be
thought-provoking in such a great way so
um
this is
interesting it's a very thoughtful and
meditative but it is a quest movie and
one of the really lovely elements of it
is that each reveal that follows the
last is believable and grounded but a
hundred percent unexpected like at no
point do you know who he's about to
speak with
what they're going to speak about but
it's still once it comes you're like
yes it makes total sense
and
rob your character is this very imposing
character
and you know you even see violence
suffered upon him he's covered in blood
throughout like he's been through it and
yet
he's constantly confronting it all with
just candor and gentleness and i was
wondering about
the inspirations for rob or what
connected you to this character i you
know i've read elsewhere that you
responded pretty quickly to the script
um but i'd love to know what was it
about rob the character
well
a couple things happened
that clicked
um
i had i had
explored
like we started with this sort of
operatic style of film performance
because i needed to break form with that
which was naturalism
and and i thought you know what i've
done that i
experimented i got what i needed out of
it i'll go back to that but right now
i need to not only remind myself but
remind
other folks other film enthusiasts that
i can
i can go back to a more quiet and
natural style of film performance so i
was looking for that and
i
said to
my reps i mean would it what have you
got that's dramatic that that is
quiet you know that
i can try something else and they sent
me pig
and i read it and right away
i i connected with it on a fundamental
intuitive level
that i had the life experience
the memories the dreams
to play rob
and nothing would need to be forced that
i i knew this man i knew what he was
about
i connected with him
i even had a dream about my beloved cat
merlin the night before i met with
michael cenoski
and i understood from the the gift of
that dream it was it was not a good
dream for me and my cat i understand
even from that so i get these like gifts
from places but i
i immediately sat down with michael
who i call archangel michael because
he uh he was somebody i never lost faith
in i knew he would show up someone that
was maybe a young filmmaker that would
he or she would show up
you know a young filmmaker that maybe
had seen a couple of my movies and after
i had become you know marginalized
from the studio system on for whatever
the reason
two or three flops or even i had lost
interest in
that program and wanted to get back to
my indie roots i had i never lost faith
that michael would show up and that
he would get it and
right off the bat we just had some
conversation about food about
our own life experiences where he was
coming from with it and and i
i knew we wouldn't be more than one or
two takes that we would just
we would just be and it would happen and
so
i had no idea that the movie was going
to communicate
on the level that it did because
pandemic had not hit yet when we were
filming it
but the most
gratifying
thing that happened the most
kind of beautiful thing that happened
was that it communicated
in such a way that when folks were
coming out of
quarantine and these feelings of
isolation much like rob in his
forest and his isolation in his own
wilderness that i had sort of gone into
with the independent going back to that
and leaving the studio system you know
as as rob is coming out of it because
the movie came out in july
also people were starting to come out of
the cobot quarantine and those feelings
so this the best compliment i got was
from cnn because it wasn't even a film
uh
commentator it was just someone who had
seen the movie and said you know this is
how we're all feeling right now you
might want to check it out and that was
like wow so the movie touched people in
a way that the timing of it lined up we
didn't get any festival love we weren't
invited to a film festival i even wrote
a letter to cannes azure for mo i said i
really think you ought to include this
in your lineup and he said well i like
what you're doing it but it's not going
to happen and i said okay well that's
that but so then neon released it in
july and what was kind of amazing about
it was almost like it was
almost like magic it was like it knew
that this is the time to do it because
the movie might speak to people who are
going through these feelings of
loneliness and isolation much like rob
and we've lost in grief
and plus my god that's perfect word
because the movie is about loss and it's
about love and the pig loss is one thing
but it's speaking about a lot that was
almost like that's one loss but there
was a deeper loss
that's only lightly touched upon and
that's the beauty of what michael and
vanessa did it was nuanced they never
overly explained what was going on and
what you've brought out what you pointed
out is so true i mean i when i watch the
movie
i'm
mystified by where's this going where is
this where where well where wow i didn't
know are we in a fight club right now
where we're now
a dinner of squad but what's going on
and you know that's because michael and
vanessa
you know it's extraordinary to me that
they're first time
filmmakers
and yet they're so confident you know so
many people said when we were trying to
get financing because i also produced
i'm trying to get them to finance the
movie they go well you know
we think he needs to get some payback or
well we want the pig to live and i would
go to michael he said no no
we're not doing that nope
she's got to die sorry and i said okay
well it's your it's your vision but
that's confidence
absolutely that's
authorial voice and it's also what makes
it special the idea that
the pig doesn't make it but also that he
never turns to the violence that he
looks to physically represent
is so meaningful it actually so the
movie both at the beginning and the end
there's kind of a mirroring of a framing
device of rob through the doorway of his
of his cabin and i found it very
reminiscent of that kind of iconic jane
john wayne shot from the searchers
which
stood out to me if only because this
film was so fundamentally at odds with
what i think john wayne's persona
represented in terms of masculinity like
this is a movie
that centers on numerous men
finding relief
and meaning through
emotional connection and vulnerability
and i think like i
revel and applaud that kind of story and
i was wondering if because you know you
were you were working hand-in-hand with
alex wolfe for a lot of it adam arkin
shows up and they have along with your
character these very significant
emotional turns that aren't always
offered to men and i was wondering if
that was kind of
in your head that perspective of
masculinity
no no no
i don't think not in those terms um
i was i didn't really look at it as male
or female i just looked at it
person who was i think the scene that
really put the hook in for me was the
scene with the child
and he's playing the pan music and i'm
talking about rob is talking about
persimmons with him i thought well this
is reminding me a little of frankenstein
but it's also so sweet so beautiful you
remember the scene where you know for
even that seems like when you think
frankenstein is suddenly playing with
the girl and they have the flowers and
then he accidentally because he's
frankenstein doesn't all his mind isn't
there you're gonna throw the girl in the
water i thought the scene was like okay
which way is the scary-looking man gonna
go with this child then all it is again
another curve oh this is just a sweet
conversation between a scary looking old
man and a child about persimmons and and
panhand music and it was just like okay
that to me is
why i need to make this movie and i
think rob could be male i think rob
could be female i i didn't look at in
terms of masculinity
yeah i really think it's because the
searchers was got planted in my head
that made me think of the masculine part
of it but also because i feel especially
an independent film over the last decade
even we've seen this growth of
male characters allowed to embrace an
emotional maturity or intelligence that
you know your 1960 like your 1950s and
60s westerns was all about the stoicism
and not allowing any of those
vulnerabilities because they would count
against you whereas
rob is this incredibly heroic character
entirely because he leads with
gentleness i i yeah and i i see what
you're saying i think you're right i do
there was this sort of
archetype about the male hero in cinema
but i like to think that i never would
have
partook in that entirely you know i like
to think that i could have been
something a bit more
if i had to go all the way back
like wells and you know kane when he's
seen rosebud or he doesn't want her to
leave and he's an old man i mean there
was i think there was still
sensitivity in in film and male film
performance
back then but it was few and far between
now that's not to say i don't
enjoy
embodying a little charles bronson every
now and then i i do have fun with that
icon because you know sometimes it's
helped me with playing in westerns or
some of the more adventure based films
i've made but
i think that
ultimately i'm most satisfied when
my performance
says something that it didn't matter
because i'm a man i mean i could
woman you know
the women and the men can both relate to
the character
certainly well that's also because you
have a full toolbox like not all of
those actors were encouraged to uh get
that tool box they were told we just
want this small part from you you're
painting from all over oh i said
painting and it was a toolbox but you
know metaphors are not my thing um
visuals are my thing so
um
but i do feel that
that if there's a genuinely truthful
performance
like i totally relate to betty davis and
all about it i could be that character
you know and if it's generally truthful
it doesn't really matter if it's
who's playing it you know you're just
responding to it
right well that again that's the purest
perspective which i think is very in
line with how you work
um something else that i loved about pig
that differs from
a lot that you've done not all of it but
is is something you mentioned before
which is that instead of like all of
this delicious meaty dialogue and
moments this is a very sparsely worded
film
and it's it's so thoughtful and in
addition to that
i found it fascinating that the camera
is often on the person that the dialogue
is being said to not the person giving
it so you're getting so many reactive
performances like there's a the moment
when you're speaking to the other chef
and watching his whole world fall apart
with your words through there like those
are it's a a very sophisticated kind of
filmmaking but i'd i'd love to hear your
thoughts on that sort of
framing if it affects your performance
or anything well i picked up on that too
and that's why when i first saw the
movie i i
haiku came to mind which is a very
strict form of poetry where it's five
six five in the syllables and so you
have to choose your
words within the syllables in the
framework so it becomes this minimalist
approach to not only dialogue but
well what it evokes is reading between
the lines it evokes a kind of
communication through silence the words
are there to
inspire
a deeper look into the space between
my father once told me a story about a
uh
a japanese
zen rock garden and the rock garden was
made by a top level um
rock
uh garden master who was no longer alive
and as the top student
was invited to go to the garden and look
at it and um
he was a
rock garden master in his own writers
but a student of the rock garden just
like hopefully i am in film acting and
he uh
he said there's something wrong you know
dig over there
and
they listened to him because he was a
top level rock garden artist and so they
they dug and
sure enough they uncovered a rock that
had been accidentally buried and then he
understood what the master wanted and so
i think that's kind of like
what the movie does in terms of its
communication it kind of makes us
think what what's going on between the
lines
where are the buried rocks and and the
way it was written which was very
unusual this doesn't happen often um
i think lent itself to that to that
haiku kind of style
that i think piggle pig ultimately
embraces
yeah it's it's
mindful there are not a lot of movies i
would describe as mindful but i
definitely think pig is so
um
along with you know there's a lot of
actors who have certain
cities associated with them robert de
niro is a new york guy
and you have
done
work and really excelled and thrived in
film set in like new orleans and las
vegas specifically and obviously pig is
ultimately in portland initially in the
woods in the pacific northwest and i
would love to hear about like how that's
a dramatic
energy change locale change how did you
respond to shooting in such a different
environment you know i gotta say that
that's a that's a very um
evocative question and it leads me to
answer
in a um
in a way that hopefully will
unpack
part of my process which is that
um
i uh i'm a big believer in the genus
loci which is latin for the genie of the
place
and
i welcome
being invited to make movies
in really far out places i made a movie
in bangkok or i made a movie in
in china or i made a movie in
greece and and i
and the movies i've made in new orleans
and yes the movies i made in vegas they
they do and and new york and l.a they
have a
they each have their own genus loci and
so portland
i was opening myself up to okay where's
the genie of this place let's have it
what have you got you know and i
guarantee you that i will not only play
i will not only sleep in dracula's
castle once but this will be the second
time but i am going to go back to
transylvania and i did in fact sleep in
his castle and i'm going to again
because i'm gonna bring that with me to
new orleans and i'm gonna go to the
genie of the place so
what what i would say is that
that also becomes
a player and an instrument in the
process
where you are you have to
and i again to
any thespians that are listening
it i invite you to open yourself to that
i mean really think about that really
feel it you know really
take the a minute to just open your mind
to the genie of the place because that
will help you
find your character
i've never heard that term before but it
makes total sense i mean there's so many
movies where they talk about
like the city is a character itself and
and then that also then reflecting back
into the actual characters makes all the
sense in the world
um
i'm sorry to interrupt but subsequently
i went to portland oregon and i had not
been there before it was important to me
to go and meet the
actual portland chefs and to go and sit
down in their restaurants and talk and
go into some kitchens and go for some
walks and and and walk around the city
and and feel it you know
yeah no i think that's that's key and
that's lucky too there's so many things
that say they're shot somewhere and
they're not actually there and pig has
such a real sense of place
um which is
just like an attention to detail that
means so much it gives that texture
um okay we have a couple of audience
questions
um
so i will dig into those first off nick
you have a very diverse deep body of
work i'm curious if you can talk about
any of your life experiences that most
affected your acting and your film
choices fyi you've been my favorite most
talented actor since i saw you in racing
arizona
oh thank you so much i do appreciate
that i would say that the
the characters that
and i will hesitate to go too deep into
my personal life experiences because
that's kind of private but
the characters that rung the most
truthfully to my own life i would say
would be joe
um the character i played in the movie i
made with david gordon green because i
had
certain things i was feeling about
my sons that i could apply to
um the to the to the performance in
terms of my relationship in that movie
with ty sheridan's character
and
this one pig because in my own life i
have had
experiences of loss and
i have
had
people in my life as well who have gone
through loss that made me feel like i
had the life experience to play those
parts
excellent
all right from dawn borchardt hi dawn
what is your favorite or most memorable
moment working with werner herzog
did he give you any great words of
wisdom i can only imagine how incredible
the set of bad lieutenant must have been
with you two
incredibles maybe one word i can imagine
so many words that the set might have
been like
yeah
well that was a that was one of those
characters where i really had to
kind of
that was an impressionistic performance
because i was completely clean and
wasn't into anything and you know trying
to find this sort of sense of recall
and
one day you know i i spent about
an hour i had this like saccharine which
is like sugar substitute in a vial
because this character was hooked on you
know all the bad stuff and i was
literally snorting saccharine and
psyching myself up thinking that okay
i'm i'm jacked up on cocaine or whatever
and and i started to really like feel it
and believe it you know that's the power
of imagination and it but it needs to be
treated with respect you know and it
needs to be looked at like okay this is
an actor preparing and then werner comes
in and says now nicholas
what is in that vial and i was like gee
come on
because he started to think i was really
on something
and i kind of took all that prep away
from me which i found
really annoying and then um
he he sounded like
see my great-grandmother saputa was from
germany and they had the exact same
accent and so
he would start talking i would just hear
my grandmother and there was one day
when my grandmother
there was a commercial going on
television
and my great-grandmother thought the
commercial was saying it was a cow
worthy commercial go see cal go see cal
go see cal and she thought it was saying
[ __ ] cat [ __ ] casual pussycat pussycat
and i just started making fun of her and
she took a mop and threw it in my face
and i was just like okay
so every time verner talked
he sounded like my great grandmother and
i thought about the no it wasn't a mop
it was a rag hitting my face and i just
put all that into the movie and then he
was like now nicholas
i have to have my lizards i have to have
my lizards in the movie
and uh
and that's another interesting story
because i had a two-headed snake at the
time
and i showed it to him we had a big
party i was living in the lurie mansion
we had a big party and showed him the
two-headed statement he was like well i
have to put this in the movie and i said
you can't this is personal and then i
donated to the audubon
museum and the snake has
later died sadly but anyway
uh he was like demanding the lizards he
doesn't have time for his lizards and
almost crying about it i was alright
vernon why don't you just cut all these
scenes out with me and just get the
lizards
because this stuff kept happening
and he always wanted he was very
anti-hollywood in that thing if you get
a big you know movie star
try to like
you know degenerate the star and and
like shoot the close up on the lizard or
shoot whatever and then
a lovely young fan said oh hey nicholas
can i get you in a picture and i said
sure and i said see werner some people
actually want me in a close-up
see he can learn learning through
lessons or learning life lessons yeah i
like that
also solid werner herzog impression
yeah it originated
the reality is bernard and i
are friends and we can talk like that
and we have had good q and a's together
good good
um all right and then we have a question
from matt love pig in all caps have you
received any feedback from the culinary
community
i i haven't uh well the only feedback i
got was just through what some of the
interviews i'd read with some of the
chefs who were my teachers and
they
they they knew that i really cared about
the process but they thought i looked
really bad they were like wow he's
really
which was perfect for the
for rob but they were um they were they
were cool you know they really helped me
they really helped me find the character
i think they're happy with it i i think
they're happy with the way the portland
culinary scene was represented
and because you you trained with a few
chefs correct so just
two portland chefs they were my teachers
uh
and and one of them taught me the
mushroom tour and then another that was
his specialty and another taught me the
the squab dish and that was their
special his specialty and they were
great you know and some of them were on
set to guide you know they would guide
me through the moves but i did take some
time to so i wanted to show the love
with the hands like the the genuine
respect for the food you know
i i find it interesting obviously
there's been a lot of
i i have to assume by people who haven't
seen the film the comparisons to john
wick and to me there's so much more
ratatouille to at least to that certain
moment the idea of
which here is sort of the stand-in for
art in general but food and its ability
to transport you to either like in this
instance to like through time and space
into a memory
yeah well that's what i really
took from the film for me as an audience
member was the power of food because the
he was not using guns or knives to fight
back he was using food and its emotional
call back when
uh the wonderful adam arkan you know has
the dinner that brings them back to his
his wife who's no longer with him and
he's like why are you doing this and
it's like that's how he's gonna get the
answer where is my pig it's he's using
his ability with food and that to me was
new i have never seen that in a movie
before
no not at all but it also reflects to
the idea of
that moment before arkhan sort of
taunting him with you have no leverage i
have all the power here like power is
what's important and then the leverage
that he does have is his skill it's his
art and his care and having that not
only valued in this narrative but
it does succeed for this character he
does
getting his truth that he's looking the
quest is completed
yeah it's kind of miraculous
and and thank you for that and i wanted
to say that
you know when when the trailer first
came out for the movie the suddenly this
john wick thing started happening and
people thought it was going to be a john
wick because that was so ingrained in
the in the culture
but but michael and vanessa they had no
idea of john wick not at all it never
came up they weren't even playing with
the mechanism of john wick and we'll
turn a corner it wasn't like that and
it's really because of those two it's
really because of michael and vanessa
that the movie
uh was so
unusual and and so full of surprises and
and they brought that power element they
did you know and i i
again the fact that they were first-time
filmmakers just extraordinary in my mind
and that's of course vanessa block and
michael cernoski vanessa is producer and
story by and michael is also story by
writer and director of pig and we're at
the end of our time but i'm very
exciting i have your number one fan here
oh great that's a trillion
i don't think you would have seen it but
she actually jumped right here when you
mentioned your cat merlin oh that exact
moment
that makes sense
that's beautiful nice um well thank you
so much for this this has been a dream
come true for me and just a lovely talk
and
i'm so happy you're here in supporting
this film and made this film and working
with new this is michael sarnoski's
directorial debut which i know inspires
so many of our directors out there
trying to like
get
going in their own art and making things
so thanks for that all the best with pig
thank you to neon and i hope that anyone
who's watching please watch pig if you
haven't already if you have please get
five other people to watch pig because
it is so wonderful and maybe someday i
will sell you a shirt that says i dig
pig and it will be a whole new thing
thank you
wonderful thanks bye
[Music]
you